[MUSIC]
We all have many decisions to make, some
are easy and straightforward, while others
can be tricky in terms of appropriateness,
effectiveness, and ethics.
Today I look forward to digging in and
exploring ethics in our personal and
professional lives.
I'm Matt Abrahams, and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast.
I am super excited to be joined
by Neil Malhotra and Ken Schatz.
Neil is the Edith M Cornell professor
of political economy at the GSB.
He also serves as the director of
the Center for Social Innovation.
Ken is the David S and and
M Barlow professor of political
economy also at the GSB.
Together Neal and Ken can teach
a core course on business ethics.
And recently they published a new
book together called Leading with
Values Strategies for Making Ethical
Decisions in Business and Life.
Thanks for being here.
>> Thank you, Matt, so great to be here.
>> Thanks so much, Matt.
>> All right, let's get going.
Neil, you and Ken teach business ethics,
can you share with us how you two think
about ethics and the role they play or
should play in business?
>> Sure, that's a great question.
I would say that the concept of the role
in business and society has changed
a lot in the last 30 years and
is going through a sea change as we speak.
And I think that probably
wouldn't be new to your audience,
given all of the social issues
that businesses are involved in.
And I would say in the 1980s, there was
a big emphasis on shareholder value,
that the primary ethical and
moral responsibility of a business was to
maximize value for its shareholders,
who are the owners of the company.
And I think kind of increasingly we've
moved to more of a stakeholder model,
where businesses have to be aware of
various stakeholder groups in society.
And this is what kind of motivated us
to write the book which is, how do you
actually rigorously and analytically think
about your role as a business leader given
all of these new challenges and
responsibilities you might have,
where various groups sort of demand
that businesses act ethically?
And we draw on a lot of intellectual
traditions ranging from psychology to
normative philosophy,
to economics, political science.
And kind of gather all those insights so
the readers can have really tangible,
actionable recommendations on how to
lead organizations in the challenging
environment we currently face.
>> I really appreciated in your book,
how you did that,
where you draw on all these different ways
of thinking and ways of studying this.
And then the very specific advice and
guidance you give is very helpful and
I love that you have some activities for
people to think through.
And I can see how it would help our
students as they prepare to enter
the business world and act ethically.
Ken, you write that effective
leaders not only know their values,
but can manage the diversity of
values within their organizations.
How do you recommend that people
identify their core values and
determine those of others on their team or
in their company?
>> I think the first thing I would
say is what not to do is to look at
the company's public statements
of its mission and values.
I think for some companies, those are very
authentic to what the company is about and
what motivates people within the company.
But when I look at those statements,
there's often a lot of similarity
across companies in those statements.
And I don't think that really reflects
the differences across companies and
amongst individuals within companies.
So I would say the first thing this
requires, and this is implicit in the idea
of managing a diversity of values, but
I think it's a mistake that some leaders
is to, don't assume that the people in
your organization share your own values.
Some of the time they do,
some of the time they don't,
some of the time some of them do,
but there's a bunch who don't and
those are the most difficult
sorts of situations.
We have this exercise, actually the
concluding chapter of the book is to have,
in which we do in our MBA class is to
have people sit down and think and
write up their own core values.
And drawing on stuff from the book but
also religious traditions,
cultural traditions, personal history
often really plays an important role in
driving people's own values.
And I think as a leader, that's
something that one can do for oneself.
One can also, you can imagine
doing this as a team exercise.
But the problem with that is some of
the time people feel they have to present
themselves a certain way in the work
context and things like that.
So it can be really tricky to figure out
the points where, disagree with oneself.
And I think that's why one of our big
important takeaways from the book is like,
well set up organizations allow for
dissent in disagreement about values and
to make it possible feasible
encouraged for people to do that.
That can be living with some conflict
that can be uncomfortable for people.
>> I really appreciate that last point
about how it can be uncomfortable but it
allows for a more free organization where
people can share their different opinions.
We have on a number of occasions
on this podcast talked
about the notion of psychological safety,
about self reflection on your position and
your attitudes.
And to that you had this list of values,
and I think that's really important.
And taking the time to just reflect
on your values and write them down,
I think can be very helpful.
And finding ways to encourage
your colleagues and
others can also help you set up an
environment where people really can feel
that it's okay to share their point
of view and to disagree with others.
So thank you for that.
Neil, you and Ken make the case that
our values lead to the moral choices we
make and motivate the actions we take.
What thoughts do you have about
how we can assess our actions?
In your book you discuss different
tests people can use and deploy.
>> Yeah, so this kind of ties to
something you mentioned earlier,
which is kind of one thing we tried to do
in the book is take abstract concepts and
convert them into tangible tests and
evaluate them.
So we have one chapter where we
talk about where organizations and
leaders can maybe go on the wrong path.
>> Right.
>> And so we kind of lay out various
tests that can prevent people
from veering in the wrong decision that
are inconsistent with their values.
For example,
we talk about bright line rules,
this is an approach many people take.
An example we give is Clayton Christensen,
the famous management scholar
who passed away a few years ago.
He had a Mormon upbringing with the LDS
and a bit, he had these bright line rules,
for example, that he was going to
use Sunday as a day of rest.
And he tells an anecdote about how he
cost his basketball team the championship
because he didn't play on that day.
But the whole point he
was trying to say is,
is that if you violate your bright line
rules then those rules become meaningless.
So as we kind of discussed
that's a really valuable and
very clear way to design a test, but
there's many situations in a complex
business environment where you can't
predict exactly what's going to happen.
So there's not going to be bright
line rules you can list in advance.
So then we talked about other tests.
So I think a very common one business
leaders talk about is the New York Times
test or The Wall Street Journal test,
which is always think the New York Times
was writing about what you did,
would you do the same thing?
And as we explain,
there's some flaws with this test.
And one of the flaws is, is that the New
York Times doesn't really write about very
much stuff that's going
on in the [LAUGH] world.
So most of the decisions we face
are not fair in those level decisions.
They are things that the media are not
going to cover but actually, have a lot of
implications on organizations, how we lead
and how people perceive our leadership.
So we talked about actually
a third test which is.
The friends and family test, would you
be comfortable telling your friends and
family about your actions and
decisions, or
are you actually hiding things
from your friends and family?
And this is actually something
that's very practical and
realistic because it
comes up all the time.
You're really not going to be on
the phone with a New York Times reporter,
but you will be talking to your spouse or
your loved ones at night and
telling them how your day went.
And I think it's actually a very telling
test where you're withholding information
because you think that there's
inconsistent with your value structure.
Now, we talk about
limitations of that test too.
For example, sometimes our friends and
family ate in a bed, us, but nonetheless,
I think we tried to kind of explain
different tests and the strengths and
limitations of each of them.
>> So I was smiling as you were talking
about the friends and family tests,
because with my two teenage boys,
we have what we call the grandma test.
What would you think if grandma found
out about what you've said or did, and
that resonated with me.
It sounds to me though that thinking
through how you will assess or
test your actions is
really important to do.
And to have a shared agreement,
not just with yourself, but
others on your team would also help.
So, I encourage everybody to think about
how will you assess those decisions and
actions that you take.
Can you talk about how situational
social environments and
norms can also influence
our moral actions?
What best practices can you suggest
to help us not only understand these
external influences but
work to align them with our values?
>> So, I like how you phrase that, Matt,
that is not treating this external
situation is something that's just
kind of fixed, and I gotta live with it,
recognizing that the situations we
put ourselves into are a choice.
And actually,
that's often the most important choice we
make that's going to determine what we do.
So I think there's this tendency in
Western cultures, specifically or
especially, and the American West and
Silicon Valley to valorize
their heroic individual.
And yeah, the thing is with
the psychologists have shown,
I'm actually not a psychologist scholar,
I'm a political economy scholar.
But I've looked at what
the lessons of social psychology,
they've shown pretty well that we are not
heroic individuals, we just aren't.
It'd be great if we were, but we aren't.
I mean, a good thing though is
that we are capable of being
great if we put ourselves
in the right situation.
So I think the first lesson is
not assuming I will do the right
thing no matter the circumstances.
I think planning ahead for taking
the circumstances that I put myself into
will shape what I will do and
maybe even shape the person I become.
And I think this is one of
the most important lessons and
things for people to think about
when thinking about jobs to take or
lines of professions to go into.
All sorts of career planning things,
is like I'm going to be part of this
organization in this situation.
Do I want to be like the people
in this organization?
Is that what I aspire to for myself?
And I think that's a really foundational,
like planning thing.
And then the other part of this is no
matter what situations we put ourselves
into, some of the times stuff is going to
come up that pushes us to do things
in ways that are out of
step with our values.
And I think the biggest lesson there
is to just try to find a way to
get oneself out of the situation,
I mean, literally physically,
I mean, immediate physical context
has a lot of effect on us.
But also emotionally, this sort of goes
back to the friends and family test.
I think it's good to bounce things off
of those who were close to those who
we trust.
Those who we trust to be willing to
criticize us because they value us and
they love us,
I think that's a really important thing.
So I think that's kind of
a long winded answer, but
I think the question you asked is probably
more important than the answer I gave.
>> That question was primed by
a discussion we had on a previous podcast
episode where I interviewed
Philip Zimbardo,
one of the most famous social
psychologists who has dedicated a lot of
his career to studying how
the situation influences people.
So, that was fresh in my mind as I was
reading that chapter of your book.
Though, the other thing you mentioned,
Ken, that I think is really critical is
that you have to have trusted others that
can give you good, clear, honest feedback.
And that can be hard sometimes
in a business setting,
because people don't want to offend or
they're afraid that there might be
political or hierarchical ramifications.
So that's important to
find those trusted others.
I love that you too dedicate time
in your business ethics class and
in your book to discuss strategies for
communication.
I had a big smile on my
face as I was reading that.
Neil, can you share the pointers you
provide around understanding both
your audience and yourself, and
framing messages to align morally?
>> Sure, and
this kind of ties to what you just said.
People are oftentimes worried in these
polarized times that there's just
a lot of disagreement, conflict,
it's hard to reach resolution.
So in the book,
we try to bridge literature on moral
philosophy with communication strategies.
And specifically, we're very influenced by
what's called moral foundations theory.
Which is the argument that everybody
has sort of these deep seated moral
intuitions and foundations,
which drive how they see the world,
their kind of senses,
just like we have touch and taste.
We have kind of moral senses
that guide how we see it.
And once you realize this, you realize
that when we disagree with someone,
it's oftentimes that they are coming and
using a different moral sense than we are.
So an example is like debates over
COVID lockdowns in the workplace or
vaccine mandates.
Some people, the moral sense they
really are attuned to is harm, so
anything they can do to reduce harm
to other people would be great.
Other people are motivated
by a moral sense of liberty.
Which is that people should have
the freedom to do what they want, and
kind of restricting their
freedom is a negative thing.
So if, for example, you want to implement
a tough COVID policy, whether it's like
a vaccine mandate or something like that,
and you come from the harm perspective.
It's a really ineffective strategy
to convince people from the liberty
perspective using language and
argument centered around harm.
So that's telling a story
how you've been told it,
not looking from their perspectives and
the stories they tell.
The most effective thing you can do is to
understand the other person's story and
frame the language and
arguments around them.
So to argue that, hey,
if you really care about liberty,
we actually need these vaccines
because this will open up
a flourishing economy that will
allow us to do everything we want.
And I think kind of this
is what framing is about,
is fundamentally about being empathetic.
And there's been a lot of
research done on perspective,
taking in how to change people's minds.
The results are just very clear, which is
the worst thing you can do is show up to
someone's house and
explain to them why they're morally wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That tends to not work very well.
Whereas, when they've tried to change
people's minds on gay marriage or
transgender rights, they start by
listening, by saying, well, tell me
a story of when you felt discriminated
against or you felt excluded.
And then they get people talking
about themselves, and they say,
well, this is what happened to this other
person, and they felt a lot like you did.
And so,
coming at it from a non-judgmental view,
listening rather than lecturing,
it tends to be most effective.
>> Yeah, you took me back to
our thanksgiving table where we
had lots of people being told
that they were morally wrong.
[LAUGH] So I appreciate that.
This notion of moral
sense is really valuable.
We talk a lot about understanding your
audience, taking their perspective,
empathy, Moral sense is yet another one of
the things to consider when we talk about
attitudes, resistance points, but
also somebody's moral perspective and how
you can adjust and adapt your messages.
So it's not just that you
have to appreciate it,
you then have to frame your message in
alignment with somebody's moral sense.
And thank you for that, and
the examples you used were very
helpful in explaining that.
Before we end,
I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I asked everyone who joins me.
Are you gentlemen up for that?
>> Sure, of course.
>> Yeah, I guess we can't
duck it if you ask everyone.
>> [LAUGH] That's true.
You would definitely stand out.
So Ken, we're going to start with you.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you have
ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title,
what would that be?
>> Your audience is not yourself.
And to really internalize that, when
communicating, I think is hard, because we
naturally kind of, talk to ourselves and
I play up things that we believe it.
>> I like how you captured it I often say
in my strategic communication classes that
the biggest mistake people make
is we start from the wrong place.
We start from saying here's what I want to
say and that puts us on the wrong path.
You're title of your slide really
emphasizes that, thank you.
Now for both of you,
I'd like you to answer who is
a communicator that you admire and why?
And Neil, why don't you go first?
>> I would say the late Steve Jobs is
someone I admired might admit, even though
people kind of disagreed with maybe his
personality or things about his decisions.
One reason I think he was
an effective communicator is that he
knew his core values and
his company's core values really well and
can motivate people based on them.
The book has a link to his YouTube
video when he came back to
Apple after he was originally fired.
And a lot of people don't remember
because it's the most valuable company in
the US now but it was a very
crappy company for a long time.
After Jobs left, the company was
basically going down the toilet and
this was also during the.com boom kind of
before it where a lot of people had a lot
of good job offers and
could have left Apple.
And I really encourage people to watch
this video to kind of see what great
communication around values and
core values is.
And he explained what is
the core value of Apple.
We are not in the business of making
boxes to help people get their work done.
We are in the business of enabling
disruptors to change the world.
And he said basically encapsulated
Apple's core value is this which is
Martin Luther King and
Amelia Earhart never had a computer,
but if they had one,
you know they would have used a Mac.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's just brilliant when you really
think about it.
And it really explains what Apple's
customer base likes to believe about
themselves and what the employees in
Apple like to believe about themselves..
And so I think just to kind of sum
opposite what he wasn't good communicator
because he was a good speaker.
He was a good communicator because
he understand his values or
was able to explain the very clearly
we'd like a simple phrase like that.
>> I love it.
And
we also use that speech in the strategic
communication class I teach, so
I'm very familiar with it, and
I do encourage everybody to look at it.
So Ken, who is a communicator
that you admire and why?
>> The communicators who I really admire
are great elementary school teachers.
>> Hah.
>> And it's because they do things I
mean they have a challenging audience to
work with.
Like we think we have a challenging
audience to teaching MBAs.
>> It is nothing.
>> It is nothing compared to what an
elementary school teacher is dealing with.
A great elementary school teacher,
they know their audience.
They know how to treat them respectfully,
but
they also know what they know
when the audience doesn't know.
So they know how to simplify and
will ruthlessly simplify their
core message to get across the stuff
the audience really needs and
to tell this as a story and
make it vivid to the students.
And I'm just in awe of
the skill it takes to do this.
I mean, this is an incredible craft.
I'm just blown away.
I've spent a fair bit of
time my daughter is now 13.
I spent a fair bit of time volunteering
in her schools over the years.
And I think back on is like that's
really impressive communication.
>> I wholeheartedly agree.
I think anybody who teaches
anyone where guilt and
shame doesn't work as a way of helping
moderate behavior it deserves an award.
And as somebody who studies
communication anxiety and
has worked a lot on my own and
helped others.
I have never been more nervous
than when I was in one of my
son's kindergarten classes.
And the teacher had to step out to take
a phone call and I had 24 kindergarteners.
I have never been more nervous
in front of an audience before.
So Neil let me ask you the third
question what are the first
three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe?
>> So that was a really tough question and
I tried to take your metaphor a little bit
literally and thought about what is
the best food that has three ingredients.
And I would say a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich is maybe I think the best
food that only had three ingredients.
>> I agree.
>> I thought about like the peanut butter
would be like one knowing yourself.
And that's kind of a big theme of our
book, which is to really understand your
own values, not think of them vaguely,
but to write them down to revisit them,
to think about them,
to be open to persuasion.
And to the jelly I would say is empathy,
which is even it's important to both
know yourself and
understand others at the same time and
how their values might
be different from yours.
And then the bread is really what makes
the peanut butter and jelly touch together
for the combination which is this balance
between being true to your own values.
Understanding others.
Persuading them using their
stories not yours/ But
also being open to persuasion yourself
>> Wow,
I've never had anybody literally
take the ask of this question and
turn it into something so the response
PB and J I think is fantastic.
Well, Ken and Neil, thank you.
You have provided us with so
many insightful tips and
guidance that will help us to be better
more ethical leaders and communicators.
Thank you so much.
And finally, good luck with your new book,
Leading with Values,
Strategies for Making Ethical Decisions
in Business and Life.
I personally took a lot of value from it
and I know everybody who reads it will be
better off and
make better decisions in the future.
Thank you both.
>> Thanks for the great conversation.
>> Thank you, Matt.
It's been great to have
a chance to talk with you.
[MUSIC]
>> Thanks for joining us for
another episode of Think Fast Talk Smart
the podcast from
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
This episode was produced by Jenny Luna,
Michael Riley and me, Matt Abrahams.
For more information and
episodes visit gsb.stanford.edu or
subscribe to our show wherever
you get your podcasts.
Finally, find us on social
media at Stanford GSB.
[MUSIC]